今日はワタミ社長ですあの
見てもらって分かると思うんですけど実は今日なぁ
この黒い雪原発が普通の威力の5倍なんですよ
5倍なのでここに5倍って書いてるんですよ威力子はいねえぞ僕は猫3個買ってなんか
のバネだけをとって1個にまとめて
まあ威力ず15倍の最強のくる行き発を作ろうと思ったんですけどなんだねぇ
これまで入らなくて
ちょっと苦戦して
今日はやろうと思ったんですけどできませんでしたちゃんという最強にしてちゃんと
飛ばそうとなんでちょっといろいろ考えてみてできるかどうかちゃんと検証しますすみ
ませんなんか
実は今日ずっと猫のレジの姉をやってたんですけど
しませんでしたなので今日はね遊びに質問コーナーのコメントをもらおうと思います
かげさまで登録者の80人入ってね本当にあざすあざすなんですけども
というわけで今日はねこの動画のコメント欄に僕にん
聞きたいこととかリクエストとカツオ何でも憶えていたことをどんどん入っちゃって
ください
いつもコーナーしてくださいっていうコメントもちょくちょく来るんで
ああああああ
まあ今日はちょっと本当に申し訳ないです全部のコメントは読めないんではー
とこあ姉ちゃんちょっとご了承いただきたいするたんで良かったらみなさん今日の動画
のコメント欄に書いてください
めっちゃ楽しみだったのにできなかったかなぁああこれちょっとテンション
んま絶対これはねしたいから
ぜひねちょっと楽しみにしてて欲しい沿っでぜひねこの動画のコメント欄に今日は
皆さんも聞きたいこととか質問とかどんどん書いちゃってください
今年中には出す予定ですぜひね
コメントガンガン海賊てくださいというゲー
今回はこういうコメントと質問コーナー用のコメントを書く動画でした
ぜひねコメント欄で皆さん
ご質問を変えてください面白い質問お待ちしております
あった
じゃあ